Charles
De Gaulle was the sort of man who turned heads.
At six foot five inches in height, he towered
over his contemporaries, and, with his regal
bearing and firm gaze, he exuded an air of
forthright self-confidence.
Throughout his life, his unswerving love for
France, coupled with his determination to
right the wrongs of the past, turned him into
a hero of the resistance movement and one
of the French Republic’s truly great statesmen.
In Today’s Biographics, we examine the very
full life of Charles De Gaulle,
Early Life
Charles Andre Joseph Marie De Gaulle was born
on November 22, 1890.
He was the third of five children to Henri
and Jean De Gaulle.
Henri was a military man who had served in
the Franco-Prussian War.
By the time his second son was born he was
a teacher at a Catholic school in the French
industrial region of Lille.
Shortly after the birth of Charles, the family
moved to Paris, where Henri took up a position
as the headmaster of the Jesuit College of
the Immaculate Conception.
Henri was a lover of history and the glory
of France.
Nights in the De Gaulle home would often be
spent with the children gathered around to
listen to their father regale them with stories
of the country’s history and the part their
ancestors had played in it.
Charles would later recall the stories his
father would tell about their most famous
ancestor, Sieur Jehan De Gaulle, a knight
who fought against the English at the Battle
of Agincourt.
The glorious history of his nation that Charles
was learning at the feet of his father came
with a distrust of the country’s natural
enemy, the British.
Henri would not allow his children to learn
the English language.
Charles’ mother, Jean, loved her country
even more than her husband.
Charles would later say that she had . . .
An uncompromising love for her country that
was equal to her religious piety.
The defeat of France at the battle of Sedan
in 1870 during the Franco-Prussian war was
a source of humiliation for all French patriots,
including the De Gaulle’s.
They seethed with the desire to avenge the
shame that had fallen upon their once mighty
nation.
They kept this ambition alive in their children,
with Henri regularly taking them to the cemetery
at Le Bourget and having them read aloud the
inscription to the dead of 1870 . . .
The sword of France, broken in their valiant
hands, will once more be reformed by their
descendants.
Even though he wasn’t the smartest of the
five De Gaulle children, Charles was their
natural leader.
He had a mischievous, dominant attitude and
he was always organizing some sort of practical
joke on one of his siblings.
When he was about six, he invented his own
language, which involved speaking French backwards.
He forced his brothers and sisters to learn
it.
They naturally objected but his insistence
paid off and they all became fluent at it.
This was an early sign of the determination
and persistent force of character that would
come to be his trademark as an adult.
A Model Soldier
Like most French boys, Charles loved to play
soldiers.
Yet, when he and his brothers lined up their
model armies on the bedroom floor, he would
exhibit a seriousness and intensity that went
way beyond a childhood game.
He always insisted on portraying the French
army and would become cold and dispassionate
during the war games as he put his total energies
into defeating the enemy.
Charles attended the Jesuit College where
his father was the headmaster.
He was a keen student who loved to read and
developed an early interest in philosophy.
By the age of ten, though, he had decided
that he was going to pursue a life in the
military.
From that point onward, Charles was single-minded
in his military focus.
At the age of fifteen, he wrote an essay in
which he projected himself forward to the
year 1930 where, as General De Gaulle, he
led the French army in defeating the Germans,
finally inflicting vengeance for the defeat
of 1870.
Charles was determined to win a place at the
military academy at Saint Cyr.
His hard work at school paid off and he was
accepted into the Academy in 1909.
However, prospective officers were required
to serve a year in the ranks before entering
officer training school and so, in October
1909, he was enlisted into the 33rd Infantry
Regiment stationed at Arras.
Four months later he won his first promotion,
to corporal.
It was usual for an aspiring officer to reach
the rank of sergeant during that first year,
but De Gaulle’s company commander, Captain
Tuguy, refused to bestow this rank upon him.
When asked why he had not promoted De Gaulle,
Tuguy commented . . .
Would you have me nominate to sergeant a boy
who would only be at his ease as the grand
constable?
In reflecting upon this time with the 33rd
Infantry, De Gaulle later made the wry remark
that the most valuable lesson he had gotten
from his year in the ranks was that if you
did the exact opposite to what you were told
by the non-commissioned officers, you would
get on fairly well.
La Grande Asperge
He entered the Military Academy of St. Cyr
in the Autumn of 1910.
He quickly earned a reputation as an arrogant
dandy with an air of superiority.
Two nicknames quickly became attached to him
– ‘Le Grande Charles’ and ‘La Grande
Asperge’.
This last title translates as ‘the great
asparagus’ and was, apparently a reference
to his stature.
At 6 foot, five inches in height he towered
over virtually everyone he met.
One of his classmates was the future General
Bethouart, commander of French troops in 1940’s
Battle of Norway.
He remembered De Gaulle as a mediocre student
who had few friends.
The fact that he graduated 13th out of a class
of 211 students in 1912 seems to indicate
that he was somewhat more than mediocre.
It was expected that a young man with the
ambition of De Gaulle would choose to join
a cavalry regiment as that was traditionally
the fastest route to promotion through the
ranks.
However, Charles had already come to the conclusion
that the days of the horse soldier were over.
He believed that future wars would be won
by the infantry.
As a result, he made the decision to return
to the 33rd Infantry at Arras.
De Gaulle spent the next two years learning
the craft of an army officer.
It didn’t take long for the lanky officer
to make an impression in the town of Arras.
Heads turned when he passed by, with people
being captivated by both his extraordinary
height and his regal bearing.
Yet, his rather caustic, cold nature repelled
more than his impressive appearance attracted.
Not long after De Gaulle’s arrival at Arras,
the 33rd received a new commanding officer,
Colonel Phillipe Pétain.
Charles developed a great deal of respect
for Petain.
In his memoirs he wrote . . .
My first colonel, Pétain, taught me the art
of command.
Petain was also impressed with De Gaulle.
On October, 1913, he recommended his promotion
to First Lieutenant.
First World War
When war broke out in August, 1914, the 33rd
Infantry Regiment, as part of the French Fifth
Army was deployed to Dinant in order to halt
the German advance throughout that region.
De Gaulle was immediately into the action,
with his first engagement on August 15th being
the Battle of Dinant.
He was wounded in the knee and sent to hospital
to recover.
When he returned to the regiment in October,
many of his men and fellow officers were dead.
Two months later, he was promoted to regimental
adjutant.
The 33rd infantry regiment became famous for
their ability to crawl out into no-man’s
land in order to spy on the enemy.
The intelligence garnered from this work won
De Gaulle the Croix de Guerre medal.
In February, 1915, he was promoted to captain.
The following month an inconsequential hand
wound became infected, leaving him out of
action for the next four months.
During the Battle of Verdun in March, 1916,
De Gaulle was wounded in the left thigh by
a bayonet and subsequently captured after
passing out from the effects of poison gas.
De Gaulle spent the remainder of the war in
a German prisoner of war camp.
He attempted to escape five times.
He attempted escape by hiding in a laundry
basket, digging a tunnel, digging a hole through
a wall, and even posing as a nurse to fool
his guards.
In letters that he wrote to his parents during
his captivity he expressed his great frustration
that he was unable to participate in the war
effort any longer.
He referred to himself as being ‘cuckolded’
and fell into a state of depression.
Following the Armistice in 1918, he was released
and returned to his parents’ home in Dordogne
in southern France.
The Inter War Years
In early 1920, De Gaulle was posted to Poland
as part of the French Military Mission to
Poland.
There he served as an instructor to the Polish
Infantry.
He served with distinction, earning the rank
of major in the Polish army and being awarded
the distinguished Virtuti Militari, Poland’s
highest military decoration.
He returned to France in 1921 and spent a
year as a military history lecturer at the
St. Cyr academy.
He then spent two years studying at the Ecole
Militaire in Paris.
He graduated with a grade of assez bien, or
‘good enough’, and was then posted to
the Rhineland area of Germany which was under
French Army occupation.
During the mid-1920’s De Gaulle worked as
a ghost-writer for his old commander at Arras,
the now Marshal Pétain.
In 1926, the two had a falling out over a
book on the history of the French soldier
that De Gaulle had ghost-written called Le
Soldat.
In October of that year he returned to the
Rhine to commence his military duties there.
In 1927, after a dozen years in the army,
De Gaulle was promoted to commandant.
He was then posted to the occupying forces
at Trier in Germany at the head of the 19th
chasseurs a pied, which was a light infantry
battalion.
De Gaulle was a hard taskmaster on his soldiers,
often pushing them beyond what was reasonable.
On one occasion he got into hot water for
throwing a soldier into prison for exercising
his right to appeal to his member of parliament
for a transfer to a less demanding unit.
Even though he had had a falling out with
Pétain, he called on his old commander to
help get himself out of the mess.
With the end of the Allied occupation of the
Rhineland in 1929, De Gaulle was posted to
Lebanon and Syria.
He served with distinction, with his commanding
officer providing him with an impressive recommendation
when he returned to France in 1931.
He then received a posting to the General
Secretariat of the Supreme War Council, based
in Paris.
His job description was as a drafting officer.
For the next six years, De Gaulle gained valuable
experience in military bureaucracy.
Over that time, he worked with government
officials in drafting bills related to the
military.
He worked on a bill for the organization of
France during the event of war, but it did
not pass the senate.
Throughout this period, De Gaulle was not
shy about voicing his opinion on the military
preparations that France was making in the
event of another European war.
He considered the line of fortifications known
as the Maginot Line, on which billions of
dollars was being spent, to be a wasted effort.
Rather than focusing on a defensive footing,
he contended that the French needed to be
pro-active through mechanized warfare that
was fast moving.
In 1934, he wrote a book called ‘Toward
A Professional Army.’
In it he outlined his plans for the Future
French Army, with a hundred thousand men and
three thousand tanks.
In 1937, De Gaulle came a step closer to realizing
this ambition when he was given command of
the 507th Tank Regiment.
With his promotion of the tank as the key
to French infantry success, he became a nationally
known figure, with people referring to him
as ‘Colonel Motors.’
France Falls
With the French declaration of war upon Germany
in September, 1939, De Gaulle was put in command
of the Fifth Army’s five tank battalions,
mostly equipped with R35 light tanks.
In early 1940, he lobbied for the position
of Secretary General of the War Council, the
government’s top military adviser, but was
passed over.
Towards the end of March 1940, De Gaulle was
given command of the newly created 4th Armoured
Division.
With the German attack on May 10th, the 4th
Armoured went into action.
On May 17th, they encountered the Germans
at Montcornet, near Laon.
It was a disaster for De Gaulle, with 23 of
90 of his tanks destroyed by mines, anti-tank
weapons, or Stukas, dive bomber and ground-attack
aircraft.
Two days later his reinforced division was
decimated for a second time.
Despite being ordered to withdraw, he fought
on, demanding even more reinforcements.
Even though this request was denied he managed
to push the Germans back to Caumont.
But this was only a temporary respite.
On May 20th, De Gaulle began to retreat in
the face of the unstoppable German advance.
On May 23rd he was promoted to brigadier-general.
On May 28th he led an attack on a German bridgehead
at Abbeville, which captured some 400 prisoners.
By the beginning of June, De Gaulle had been
recalled to Paris where he was offered and
accepted the position of under-secretary of
state for National Defence for War.
On June 8th, he met with Army Commander in
Chief Weygand who was about to announce the
French surrender.
When De Gaulle tried to convince him to fight
on, Weygand laughed despairingly.
The following day De Gaulle flew to London
where he met British Prime Minister Winston
Churchill for the first time.
His attempts to convince Churchill to put
more RAF fighters into the Battle for France
fell on deaf ears.
Upon his return to Paris, he wanted to defend
the city to the last man, but Weygand had
other ideas.
The government was relocated to Tours, where
a series of meetings with British officials
were held.
During these meetings, De Gaulle’s fighting
resolve impressed the Brits, standing in stark
contrast with the other French leaders.
On June 16th, De Gaulle was back in London
discussing the logistics of a troop withdrawal
to French North Africa.
When he returned to France later that day,
he discovered that Prime Minister Reynaud
had resigned to be replaced by Marshal Pétain,
who was intent on signing an armistice with
the Germans.
De Gaulle now fled France for London ahead
of the German take-over.
On June 18th, Churchill offered him air time
on BBC radio to address the French people.
In the speech, De Gaulle encouraged his countrymen
to be brave during the occupation, resisting
it as best they could.
The next day he gave another broadcast.
This time he was more critical of the Pétain
government, denouncing it as illegitimate.
On June 22nd, following the signing of the
armistice, De Gaulle took to the BBC again.
He denounced the surrender and again declared
the French government illegitimate.
On June 28th, the British government recognized
De Gaulle as the leader of Free France.
His government in exile consisted of three
colonels, twelve captains and three battalions
of legionnaires.
Over the following months, De Gaulle’s main
weapon was the BBC radio.
He would give broadcasts an average of three
times per month, denouncing the occupation
government based in Vichy and urging Frenchmen
to resist the occupation.
The Pétain government sentenced De Gaulle
to death in absentia.
Throughout the war years, De Gaulle was able
to slowly build up the Free French Army.
On 21st April, 1943 he boarded a plane en
route to Scotland to inspect his navy.
The plane almost crashed on take-off and it
was later found that it had been sabotaged
using acid.
In May 1943, De Gaulle moved his headquarters
to French Algiers, where he became the head
of the French Committee of National Liberation.
He became involved in the planning for the
D-Day, invasion, although the Americans and
British became increasingly frustrated with
his insistence that he was the rightful leader
of France.
He returned to Britain on June 4th, 1944 whereupon
Churchill asked him to address the French
people over BBC radio in anticipation of the
allied invasion.
However, the script he was given did not acknowledge
him as the legitimate interim ruler of France
and so he refused to deliver it.
Reclaiming France
In the wake of the D-Day invasion of June
6th, 1944 the Free French Army, under the
leadership of General de Lattre Tassigny,
landed in southern France and were instrumental
in pushing back the Germans.
On June 14th, De Gaulle returned to France.
Travelling through newly liberated Norman
towns, he was well received by the townspeople.
He established the capital of Free France
in Bayeux and then set off to Rome where he
met with the newly installed Italian government.
From there he flew to Washington for his first
meeting with President Roosevelt.
The visit was a strained one, with Roosevelt
not providing the usual privileges of a visiting
head of state.
De Gaulle pushed for the allies to prioritize
the liberation of Paris, fearing a communist
take-over.
But there was no strategic priority for the
allies to focus on Paris.
Still, through De Gaulle’s insistence, Supreme
Allied Commander Dwight Eisenhower agreed
that Paris would be prioritized out of humanitarian
and symbolic need.
He also permitted the Free French Army to
be the first to enter the French capital.
On Saturday, August 26th, De Gaulle entered
Paris in a triumphal march down the Champs
Elysees.
As his procession made its way toward the
Notre Dame Cathedral, it came under machine
gun fire from Vichy government militia.
A BBC reporter who was present noted De Gaulle’s
demeanor as he confidently strode forward
. . .
General de Gaulle walked straight ahead into
what appeared to me to be a hail of fire ... but
he went straight ahead without hesitation,
his shoulders flung back, and walked right
down the centre aisle, even while the bullets
were pouring about him.
It was the most extraordinary example of courage
I have ever seen.
Upon reaching the Great Hall of Hotel de Ville,
De Gaulle spoke before an ecstatic crowd.
His inspiring message included these words
. . .
Paris!
Paris outraged, Paris broken, Paris martyred,
but Paris liberated!
Liberated by itself, liberated by its people
with the assistance of the armies of France,
wit De Gaulle commuted around a thousand of
them.
h the support and assistance of the whole
of France!
... The enemy is faltering but he is not yet
beaten.
He is still on our soil.
It will not suffice that we, with the assistance
of our dear and admirable allies, will have
chased him from our home in order to be satisfied
after what has happened.
We want to enter his territory, as is fitting,
as conquerors.
... It is for this revenge, this vengeance
and this justice, that we will continue to
fight until the last day, until the day of
the total and complete victory.
With his bold and triumphant entry into Paris,
De Gaulle won the respect of the world.
In the days that followed the allied leaders
made statements recognizing his government
as the legitimate ruler of France.
The provisional Government of the French Republic
was established on September 10th, 1944.
De Gaulle then set out on a tour of the country.
In each city he freely mixed with the crowds
with no regard for his own safety.
Towards the end of 1944, a Legal Purge was
established to punish traitors during the
occupation and remove the last vestiges of
the Vichy Government.
Over the course of the purge around 2,000
people were sentenced to death.In May, 1945
the Germans surrendered, signing an armistice
with France in Berlin.
However, on the very day that victory in Europe
was proclaimed, May 8th, riots broke out in
French Tunisia.
Twelve days later, the French artillery fired
on demonstrators in Damascus, leaving hundreds
dead.
This event caused the ever testy relationship
between De Gaulle and Churchill to reach a
low ebb. Churchill commented that De Gaulle
was ‘a great danger for peace and to Great
Britain.’
The New France
The French Constituent assembly unanimously
elected De Gaulle as head of the French government
on November 13th, 1945.
After two months of struggle with the Communists
within his government he abruptly resigned
and formed the right-wing Rally of the French
People.
He believed that his popularity as a war hero
would propel him back to power, but this gamble
failed to pay off.
After three years in the political wilderness,
he left the party and politics behind.
The Algerian Crisis
De Gaulle then retired from public life to
write his memoirs.
In 1958, a crisis in Algeria brought him back
to politics.
The Algerian National Liberation Front was
waging a war for independence and De Gaulle
was seen as the kind of strong national leader
who could quash it.
He was returned to the Presidency and proceeded
to use brutal force to put down the rebels.
Bu these harsh methods backfired.
The Algerian people were driven further towards
independence, while around the world’s there
was condemnation against the French government.
Under intense pressure from within his country
and abroad, De Gaulle finally granted independence
to all thirteen French African colonies in
1962.
As the Cold War developed, De Gaulle advocated
the development of a French nuclear arsenal.
The country became the world’s fourth nuclear
power in February, 1960.
Three years later, De Gaulle refused to sign
the Partial Test Ban Treaty.
In 1965, he was re-elected for a second seven-year
term as French President.
He ran his government and his country with
a heavy-handed, dogmatic style that often
drew criticism.
In early, 1969 he called for a nationwide
referendum on the reform of the senate.
When his proposal was rejected by the people,
he offered his resignation, following through
on a televised promise made two days before
the referendum.
End of the Line
At the age of 78, having lived an extraordinarily
full public life, De Gaulle retired to write
an updated version of his memoirs.
He died suddenly on November 9th, 1970 while
watching TV.
He complained to his wife that he was feeling
pain in his neck and then collapsed to the
ground.
He died within minutes.
The autopsy revealed that he had suffered
from a ruptured blood vessel.
The funeral of Charles De Gaulle on November
12th, 19070 was the largest in French history.
Today he ranks along Napoleon as among the
greatest of French leaders.